last week I told you that former Russian
spy sergey skripnikov agent in england
the UK has determined that it has
Russia's fingerprints all over it
fired Secretary of State Rex Tillerson
agrees the White House does not agree
and now another Russia dissenter has
been found dead this time it's Nikolai
Glushko who was a 68 year old discovered
dead by his friends and family cause of
death not clear the counterterrorism
unit is involved in the investigation
which at least tells us something about
how British law enforcement authorities
are at least potentially seeing the
death so far there is nothing so far
directly connecting the sergey
skripnikov his daughter they are both
still in critical condition in a British
hospital - this what we know about
glushko is that he fled Russia about
eight years ago he was given political
asylum in the UK and there's a very sort
of dark anecdote to this story where
five years ago glushko said he's on a
Russian hit list and that he was one of
the few people remaining on the list who
hadn't been killed right so he said
Alexander Litvinenko who was famously
killed with polonium poisoning was on
the list he listed others and at the
time he said I don't see anyone left on
the list apart from me and now he turns
up dead I mean it's just all very very
dark and the big picture of this is that
it's yet another Russian exile who at
one point had a pretty cushy insider's
gig in Russia
Glushko for example ran the Russian
airline Aeroflot and was later accused
of all sorts of corruption and taking of
money yet another one of these people
who died under what I mean it's just a
very general term but died under
mysterious and odd circumstances and
there are now at least 15 Russians that
American intelligence agencies believe
have been assassinated in the United
Kingdom I imagine that I would be
endlessly paranoid if I were one of
these people even when I went to like a
restaurant and ordered food I'd be
wondering if the food had been poisoned
and I guess he can't really live that
way maybe after
years of that you just sort of concede
and accept that it might be coming you
won't know exactly when you just kind of
have to live your life but it seems to
me that it would be a very very
difficult existence and listen it
doesn't have to be poison right you
might accidentally slip on a banana peel
right out of a 20th storey window in a
building and that can that happens to
the best of us happens could happen at
any time total accident nothing
suspicious about it whatsoever you'd
think that Russia would lay low for a
little while because of all the deaths
that they've orchestrated you know even
alleged u.s. presidential election alive
so much spotlight on them yeah you think
they would hold back a little no no no I
think it's you one would think that
right but they are so brazen that they
do aren't doing it and Theresa May has
announced the British prime minister
that twenty-three known Russian spies in
the UK are being kicked out as a result
of I guess what's being called Putin's
indifference to the sergey skripnikov
right now we don't have particular
reason to think is connected to the
Glushko of situation
send me your thoughts on the following
question about this what's the endgame
and how does it end i won't say more
that's the question i have for you
today's program is made possible in part
by fruit or fruit or is a social
forecasting game where players come
together and compete with each other to
predict future events you open up the
game on your phone or web browser you'll
see a whole range of forecasts covering
topics across the board from politics to
sports and everything in between you
wager on predictions about real world
events using for tours in game fake
currency and you earn more of this
currency every time you make a
prediction that comes true
you can show off your prediction skills
to friends and improve your forecasting
ability I'm even on Fateh or you can
find my account and follow me by
clicking the link in the description if
you're watching this on YouTube
this week on futur I pose the question
will there be a congressional hearing
regarding the Trump sexual assault
allegations what do you think click the
link in the description and place your
bets and you can browse the politics
category on futur to wager on other
predictions sign up now at root or calm
start making your forecasts on political
topics and tons of other topics totally
free available on both Android and iOS
as well as on web browsers that is fut
you you are dot-com